الآن ريتشارد نحن نبحث أه في
أوائل الأسبوع المقبل
أه الفريق العلمي يمر
بنوع من المراحل النهائية من
دراسة فردية قوية للغاية 45000
غطت ثلاث قارات وثماني
دول أه
بعض تلك البلدان تشمل جنوب
إفريقيا والبرازيل
وذلك  نسمع عن السلالات الجديدة التي
تقدم
أه تعرف فرصة حيث ربما
سنكتسب بعض الأفكار حول بعض
هذه السلالات الجديدة بمجرد
الانتهاء من التسلسل
ولكننا نبحث في موعد لا يتجاوز أوائل
الأسبوع المقبل
إذا كان هذا هو الحال عندما يكون هذا  هذا
هو كم طول قطعة الخيط
أه السؤال عندما يحتمل أن تكون أول ضربة
للذراع هذا سؤال رائع من حيث
الوظيفة الأولى بالترتيب وهو
يفترض الكثير من أه لو أه لذا بالتأكيد نريد
أه الحصول على هذا الاستخدام الطارئ  إذن
أه بناءً على بعض أقراننا
الذين مروا أسبوعين في الوقت المناسب ،
نريد التأكد أيضًا
من موافقة السلطات الحكومية
على منشآتنا التصنيعية ،
ولا أتوقع أي
انتكاسات بسبب  أنا أكره التكهن بموعد ظهور ذراع
الطعن الأول ، فسنعتمد على dr paul stoffels لإعطاء هذه
المعلومات في غضون يومين
هنا مفهومة عندما تحصل عليها
ويفترض المرء أنها ستكون أقرب  وليس
لاحقًا ،
حيث يكون لقاحك مختلفًا ،
فهو لا يتطلب أي تبريد كبير بشكل
صحيح وهو
فردي ويفترض أن لديه معدل فعاليته
وليس لدي أي سبب للشك في
أنه سيكون بأعداد كبيرة مثل
الجميع  مكان آخر ،
أين هو أكبر سوق لك لهذا
الصبي ، هذا سؤال رائع
أعتقد الآن ،
آه كل سوق هو سوق كبير ، ونحن
نعلم أنه من
خلال عقودنا من البحث في
الأمراض المعدية ، أحد أفضل
الأشياء التي يمكننا القيام بها لإيقاف الوباء
وحتى المتغيرات المثيرة
هي أن يقوم الناس بتلقيحها لذلك
لدينا اتفاقيات توريد مع الولايات المتحدة
أه مع الاتحاد الأوروبي
وكذلك أه
التحالف العالمي للقاحات
والتحصينات
لتطوير أه أجزاء من العالم  د لذلك
نرى هذا
كفرصة عالمية حاجة عالمية بصراحة تامة
من حيث
معالجة ما تعرفه في
طليعة أذهان الجميع عبر
المجتمع.
سمعت
من شركة فايزر ومادونا
وقلت لنفسي لماذا
يزعجونني ، أعني إذا كان هناك عداء أمامي
وثاني وثالث لماذا يشارك الجميع
في هذه اللعبة ،
نعم ، استمع ، فكر في ذلك الوقت إذا
فكرت في
أنني سأصنف هذا  باعتبارها معجزة طبية
حقًا للاعتقاد بأننا في
هذه المرة من العام الماضي ريتشارد أم
لم نكن نعرف حتى سلالة أو
تسلسل الفيروس نفسه واليوم
نتحدث هنا
على أعتاب الحصول على لقاحين
تمت الموافقة عليهما بالفعل ،
تهانينا للفايزة  و Roderna ومن ثم من
المحتمل أن يكون لقاحنا هنا في غضون يومين
مع بعض البيانات التي تنتظر الموافقة
كما تعلم ، أعتقد أنه في الوقت الذي لم
يكن أحد يعرف فيه ما الذي سينجح ، كان لدينا
قدر كبير من التوثيق  دليل
على عملنا في إيبولا وفيروس نقص المناعة البشرية مع
هذه المنصة المعينة
أنه سيكون آمنًا ومقبولًا ،
لقد درسنا أكثر من مائة ألف
فرد والتجارب السريرية التي أدت
إلى هذا اللقاح المرشح
الذي كنا ننتظره وما
سنراه نأمل في  الأيام القليلة هي
الفعالية
ولا يمكن لأحد أن يتوقع حقًا ذلك ، لذلك
أعتقد أنه كان من الذكاء أن يكون لديك
عدد من اللقطات على الهدف إذا كنت ستفعل ذلك من قبل
صناعة علوم الحياة
لمعالجة هذا الوباء ، فنحن نعلم أن
الصحة الجيدة هي نوعًا ما أولاً
وقبل كل شيء من حيث المصطلحات  من امتلاك اقتصاد جيد